[Música]
y comenzamos revista de prensa repasando
lo más importante de la actualidad
internacional
rosa pérez más de bienvenida al estudio
como ésta buenos dias maria clara bien
gracias a usted muy bien gracias le
propongo que iniciemos precisamente con
la noticia que estábamos viendo y es el
arresto y la muerte del segundo
sospechoso como está cubriendo esto los
medios canadienses empecemos por the
globe and mail pues encontramos un poco
con la misma dicotomía en los titulares
que hemos seleccionado en las distintas
portadas y es que por un lado hay alivio
y tranquilidad porque se termina estos
cuatro días de búsqueda y las
autoridades han dicho que vuelve a haber
seguridad pública en relación con el
caso de esta investigación por haber
haya digamos capturado a los dos
sospechosos sin embargo recordemos que
los dos sospechosos han acabado
falleciendo por lo que se dificulta
muchísimo encontrar las razones y los
motivos de este apuñalamiento masivo de
hecho the globe and mail titula la
búsqueda termina con la muerte del
fugitivo por los acuchillamientos
masivos en sax tetuán en el sur de
canadá y bueno recuerda un poco lo que
comentábamos
la policía finalmente capturó ayer a
myles anderson el segundo sospechoso que
se sospecha también que pudiera haber
digamos asesinado a su hermano que fue
encontrado previamente muerto por
heridas no auto infligidas pero que sin
embargo el segundo sospechoso mike
sanderson como decíamos tras ser
capturado tras una persecución en una
autopista falleció en el hospital
digamos por heridas que sí parecían auto
infligidas y que dice the national post
o acerca de esta noticia rosa dramático
arresto en el lateral de una autopista
rural termina con la búsqueda y vemos en
la portada de nuevo no este denominador
común las imágenes de las víctimas de
estas diez personas asesinadas la
mayoría pertenecientes a la comunidad de
james smith y dice el national post otro
caso por dejar en libertad a criminales
violentos demasiado rápido no y es que
sanderson estaba en libertad provisional
a pesar de tener dos décadas digamos de
historial criminal y que hacía meses que
no se reportaba antes su agente de la
condicional fue una tragedia en canadá
ahí lo reporta por un tostador también
destaca los rostros de las víctimas como
veíamos con sus edades que van de los 23
a los 78 años y dice sospechoso atrapado
muere bajo custodia policial y destaca
una cita de las víctimas teníamos que
envejecer juntos las personas que
murieron en los apuñalamientos masivos
que conmemoran que conmocionan a una
comunidad pequeña y unida son recordados
como héroes bueno le propongo que ahora
cambiemos de noticia y nos vayamos a
drazile continuemos con el análisis de
cómo han sido estos actos que ha
protagonizado el presidente y candidato
ya ir bolsonaro y empecemos con hugo l
noticias también hay consenso en el
análisis de estos actos y básicamente se
reprocha al presidente jair bolsonaro
que haya utilizado esos actos
institucionales en conmemoración del
bicentenario de independencia de brasil
para hacer campaña electoral no las
noticias uol destacan integrantes sea de
tribunales superiores del ministerio
público federal de la procuraduría
general de la república y especialistas
en derecho electoral contactados por uol
avalan que los actos del 7 de septiembre
realizados y río de janeiro
pueden configurar un abuso de poder
político y económico abuso económico
porque se habrían usado recursos
públicos para financiar una campaña
electoral que habría desequilibrado la
balanza entre las distintas candidaturas
abuso político dice es cuando un
candidato usa su posición de poder para
influenciar al elector por medio de su
autoridad lo que habría hecho jair
bolsonaro usando su digamos al cargo de
presidente para digamos influir en su
campaña para la reelección así lo
denunciara la campaña de lula ante los
tribunales y de hecho también wall cita
a un magistrado del tribunal supremo que
destaca que de hecho ni en brasilia ni
en rió bolsonaro mencionó de hecho el
bicentenario sino que usó su tribuna
para hablar no de las consignas de su
campaña como digamos la prohibición del
aborto e ir en contra de la ideología de
género de la prensa de la izquierda del
movimiento de los sin tierra etcétera y
foliada de sao paulo que dice compara
este discurso con el del año pasado en
que recordemos hubo muchísimo ruido
alrededor de la posibilidad de un
golpe de estado también en esta misma
fecha en el 7 de septiembre dice que en
este caso bolsonaro rebajó un poco sus
ataques al sistema judicial quizás para
dar una imagen más suave a tres semanas
de esta primera vuelta presidencial
carta capital dice que en río de janeiro
bolsonaro defendió a empresarios
investigados por decir que financiarían
un golpe de estado si ganaba lula
también atacó a lula no y dijo que la
izquierda quiere volver al escenario del
crimen que el mal quiere volver al
escenario del crimen en brasil y o'globo
muy brevemente dice que bolsonaro siguió
las pautas de steve banon el conocido ex
consejero del ex presidente
estadounidense donald trump y que lo
importante en palabras la llevaron en
consignas seguidas por bolsonaro no es
defender una verdad no es defender
ciertos argumentos sino generar ruido y
que los enemigos finalmente son los
medios de comunicación y en este caso
insistimos como decíamos al ser
retransmitidas estas ceremonias por las
televisiones públicas youtube
redes sociales dice o globo de hecho
malo gas para en este blog del globo
bolsonaro inundó de ruido todo el país
bueno rosa y muy muy rápidamente
cuéntenos una tradición que se recuperó
en eeuu en la casa blanca sí porque
después de diez años se recuperó esta
tradición en que el presidente
actualmente en el cargo hablamos de joe
biden invitó a él a uno de los ex
presidentes en este caso a barack obama
y al ex primera dama michelle obama para
revelar sus retratos oficiales no que
quedan para la historia de eeuu algo que
se detuvo después de que obama invitará
yours wish y una tradición que se pausó
durante los años de donald trump rosa
gracias por esta revista de prensa y
nosotros continuamos con nuestro primer
invitado del día